what
[Laughter]
oh yeah all dressed
this is exciting
i've been explaining these to margot
robbie
who loves snacks and doesn't doesn't
seem seems to be totally baffled by the
idea of an all an all-dress chip but it
does exist
[Music]
hi i'm ryan gosling and this is snack
wars for lab
bible all right
[Music]
that's putin yeah
no idea what that is so that's a pork
pie
whoa
have you had this before uh yeah
this is um
there's got to be a better way to to
bite this i don't want to create a gift
factory here
[Laughter]
oh yeah
i mean
yes so am i pronouncing it
you are
i don't like that its name is
puts in
i wish it were not puts in okay
americans say poutine what are you
saying you're saying i just said i'm so
sorry pretend oh you don't need to
apologize
it is that
unfortunately this is
wow
okay well just textually i'm gonna i'm
already we're having a problem
feel free to put some mustard on as well
okay
but then are we judging the thing or are
we judging sauces does it need mustard
so it's like the male like mustard
excuse me
okay is there like a jelly in here is
that a meat is that a meat jelly uh yeah
yeah oh
that does not
sound good
yeah
i mean gravy's a gravy's like a metaphor
for things going good right it's all
gravy yeah meat jelly is not meat jelly
is like something someone calls you in
junior high and you never let it down
i'm gonna go
poutine
some people love them some people hate
them too but i love them you love them i
love them and in what situation are you
eating that like on it
you would house that right now
she did
wow
the namo bars yeah and
tea cakes
where's the tea
right this is not a controlled
experiment how can i make
is it supposed to go with tea
is that part of its charm i mean it
seems like it's pretty vital
to the tea cake it's just a cake
oh i'm looking i'm liking that part of
it
this is fun
that was very satisfying this has my
name on it yeah oh
[Music]
yeah that's classic that's a canadian
classic this
this is fun
wow
i'm gonna go with this there's more
options yeah you can destroy it yeah
and then enjoy it
that's this new tagline
but you know i feel like there's more
ways to enjoy that you can i bet you do
you have a strategy when you eat this
does everyone do it differently is it
kind of like not seeing that
you never seen that
oh no
how's that poor play it's actually still
going on
i heard that i saw it
this is uh
there's no need for that still do it
what
[Laughter]
oh yeah all dressed
this is exciting i've been explaining
these to margot robbie
who loves snacks and doesn't doesn't
seem seems to be totally baffled by the
idea of an all an all-dressed chip but
it does exist
what does old dress mean
what doesn't it's all of that it's
everything
look at that and this is a monster munch
okay
what are those what's the shape
[Applause]
monster
oh yeah got like funyun vibe it's like a
funyun with less fun
the shape is good though
because it's yeah that part's fun
okay it's been a while since then
i shouldn't have done that first it kind
of destroyed my taste buds yeah
i can't touch anything
there's something about this monster
munch that's
i want to explore more okay
yeah do you want another one no not
right now
but i mean i would revisit the monster
munch
maybe the monster munch it's just it's
more it's more exciting right now
i don't recognize any of these
so that's
yeah
so that's like dairy milk we have them
as kids and then turtle bites there oh
yeah okay turtles sure i got it okay
yeah
here we go
oh
yeah
it's going to take a minute
it's too
chocolate here that was delightful okay
again there's just so much more going on
with that one
this one didn't have a face this is what
i mean this is just it's nothing
turtle-ish but there's no turtle
involved
no turtles were harmed
in the making of that
that frog really
yeah
i'm gonna go turtle
[Music]
oh yeah
what's that a greg's sausage roll yeah
so that's a british bakery bags that
everyone loves this
so every high street
and then the other one
maple syrup and pancakes
i feel like i'm on the great
british bake off
whoa is that sausage
wow it's just like a it's like a fancy
hot dog take a hot dog in a tuxedo you
guys i see what you're doing
you're just classing up the joint
excuse me
okay
okay it's got pork pie vibes
i mean look at this just
it's just texturally this has so much
more going on for it now
no are you are you going sausage roll
i would i would also eat that
what this
but what about that
yeah that's that's
it's obviously i mean it's it's a
landslide for this game canada one okay
the canadian and me will kids won't
allow me to gloat about it
so this is my very canadian reaction
well that's nice
cheers
if you want to take everybody won though
right because it's like
uk canada the queen won today
the queen one yes okay
oh that's awful that is so bad
oh
is that meant to be a good beer
[Music]
hi lad bible i'm margot robbie i'm going
to be eating a load of australian and
british snacks and telling you which is
the far superior one which i'm